well first the grammys now the countdown
is on for the nfl draft which is being
held right here in las vegas yeah so
this has been in the works for quite
some time preparations well underway
kevin martin went to check out one of
the first structures that's going up
before this big event
if you build it they will come we are
getting closer and closer to the nfl
draft that of course will be held right
here on the las vegas strip and one of
the first visible signs the draft
theater that is going up right behind me
located behind the high roller at the
link promenade you'll find the draft
theater which will house the main stage
and will act as the central hub for all
draft activities including where pick
announcements will be made by
commissioner roger goodell and other
special guests on day two and three of
the draft the las vegas convention and
visitors authority approved 2.4 million
in public dollars to spend on putting on
the nfl draft of course the nfl
originally planned on holding the draft
event here in las vegas in 2020 but was
canceled because of the coven 19
pandemic so the countdown is now on for
april 28th of course this is just the
beginning of the construction very soon
the entire strip will be decked out for
the nfl draft reporting behind the high
roller kevin martin live local now